Musique grandiose
...
Musique militaire
-L'ordre du jour
appelle la discussion
du projet
portant séparation
des églises et de l'Etat.
La République
assure la liberté
de conscience
et garantit
le libre exercice des cultes.
-Si l'Eglise ne peut
se passer des subsides
de l'Etat, c'est qu'elle est morte.
-C'est scandaleux !
-Toutes les opinions
pourront s'exprimer...
-Les ennemis de la République
auraient beau jeu.
-Voulez-vous détruire
le catholicisme,
anéantir la religion ?
-Vous êtes plus papiste
que le pape !
-Scandaleux !
-Vous ouvrez les nerfs
de l'agitation religieuse !
-Veuillez faire silence.
-La France
n'est pas schismatique !
Elle est révolutionnaire !
Applaudissements
Nous ne faisons pas
une oeuvre
de brutalité.
Nous faisons une oeuvre
de sincérité.
-Plus de ces lois abominables
qui permettent
de chasser nos religieux !
-Traître à la France !
-Vive la France catholique !
-Il faut d'abord savoir respecter
la liberté d'autrui !
-Ces propos sont scandaleux !
-Au lieu de désarmer l'Eglise,
vous lui donnez des armes !
-Voyez-vous cela !
-J'expose mon opinion !
-Respectez le déroulement
de la séance !
-La guerre
que vous nous déclarez
est la guerre
que vous nous apportez.
-Ca suffit !
-Une confiscation n'est pas
une solution équitable !
-Quel est votre but ?
-L'humanité ira loger un jour
à l'enseigne des étoiles,
mais nous, libres penseurs,
telle est la séparation
que nous voulons !
Musique haletante
...
-Je vous dis que non !
Protestations
-Eh bien cela n'est pas
ma conception
de la libre pensée,
du moins tel que je l'interprète.
Musique intrigante
...
Une cloche sonne.
-La République peut-elle accepter
le port ostensible
de signes religieux ?
*-Laïcité imposée, non, jamais !
Cris
Qui doit financer
les édifices du culte ?
-Le droit
pour nos enfants !
-L'Europe doit-elle revendiquer
ses origines chrétiennes ?
La France doit-elle entretenir
une relation
privilégiée avec le Vatican ?
Autant de polémiques
et de sujets brûlants.
Musique intense
En 1905, déjà, les élus de la Nation
se posaient les mêmes questions.
A l'Assemblée nationale,
des volumes reliés
renferment l'histoire
de la laïcité à la française.
...
Une histoire ancienne,
mouvementée, violente, même.
...
La Révolution française
a rompu l'unité de l'Etat
et de la religion.
Le roi n'est plus
le représentant
de Dieu sur Terre.
Les biens du clergé
sont confisqués,
des prêtres sont exécutés.
La France est ravagée
par la guerre civile.
Cris et coups de feu
C'est pour ramener la paix
religieuse que Napoléon Bonaparte
négocie avec le pape Pie VII.
En 1801, il signe le Concordat.
La religion catholique
est officiellement reconnue
comme celle de la majorité
des Français
Les prêtres
deviennent des fonctionnaires
chargés d'assurer
le service public des cultes.
Ils perçoivent un traitement mais
doivent jurer fidélité au régime.
Les pasteurs protestants,
les rabbins,
seront logés à la même enseigne.
Mais Napoléon ajoute
une série d'articles organiques
qui réglementent jusqu'à
l'habit des prêtres
et leur interdit toute initiative
sans la permission
du gouvernement.
Première cause de conflit :
ces articles organiques ne seront
jamais reconnus par l'Eglise.
Seconde cause de conflit :
cette Eglise fonctionnarisée
va soutenir tous les régimes
autoritaires et monarchiques
qui se succèdent au 19e siècle.
Alors l'opposition républicaine
devient
farouchement anticléricale.
Dès 1869, Gambetta réclame
la séparation
des églises et de l'Etat,
c'est-à-dire l'abolition
du Concordat.
Le cléricalisme, voilà l'ennemi.
Musique pesante
Quand ils arrivent au pouvoir,
les républicains laïcisent le pays.
Deux France s'opposent, celle
du curé et celle de l'instituteur,
celle du croyant
et celle du libre-penseur.
A partir de 1902,
on assiste
à des batailles rangées
que suscite
la politique anticléricale
du gouvernement d'Emile Combes.
Expulsions
des congrégations religieuses,
rupture des relations diplomatiques
avec le Vatican...
Le Concordat devient inapplicable.
Eclate enfin l'affaire des fiches.
On découvre que le général André,
ministre de la Guerre,
fait ficher les officiers
qui vont à la messe.
Le scandale est tel
que le gouvernement Combes
finit par être renversé.
C'est alors que s'engage la grande
bataille parlementaire de 1905.
Musique douce
...
Le nouveau président du conseil,
Rouvier,
voudrait éviter
la guerre religieuse,
mais le 10 février,
les députés votent la tenue
d'un débat sur la séparation.
Le ministre des Cultes,
Jean-Baptiste
Bienvenu-Martin,
dépose un projet de loi.
Sous la présidence
de Ferdinand Buisson,
une commission spéciale
prépare le débat.
Une cloche résonne.
Le 21 mars 1905
s'ouvre la première séance
de la discussion parlementaire
qui va durer toute l'année.
Roulements de tambour
...
Un débat fleuve, 48 séances
de débats passionnés,
1500 pages de comptes-rendus
au Journal officiel.
...
Député du Finistère,
l'abbé Gayraud,
au nom de l'Eglise,
va défendre
une motion visant
à ajourner le débat.
...
Brouhaha
-Monsieur le président !
...
Brouhaha
-La séance est ouverte.
L'ordre du jour appelle
la discussion du projet
et de plusieurs propositions de loi
portant
séparation des églises
et de l'Etat.
La parole est à monsieur
l'abbé Gayraud.
Musique à suspense
...
-Messieurs...
Je ne crois pas que depuis 1789,
un débat plus important
que celui
qui s'ouvre aujourd'hui
ait eu lieu
dans une chambre française.
-Parfaitement, oui !
-Je ne recule pas devant
l'expression de mes pensées
ni devant l'affirmation
nette et précise
de la doctrine catholique.
Je vais donc, si vous le permettez,
vous dire ici très franchement
ce que l'Eglise catholique enseigne
et ce que tous
les fidèles enfants
de cette Eglise
croient relativement à la séparation
de l'Eglise et de l'Etat.
Pour nous, messieurs...
l'idéal des rapports entre l'Eglise
et l'Etat ne saurait être
la séparation.
Pour nous, l'idéal,
c'est l'union de la société civile
et de la société religieuse.
-C'est la domination
du pape !
Protestations
et applaudissements
-L'union pour la paix
des consciences,
pour la tranquillité publique !
Et ne croyez pas que le Concordat
napoléonien réalise cet idéal.
Ne croyez pas que nous considérions
le Concordat
comme l'expression fidèle
de la doctrine catholique.
Donc ce Concordat,
qui fait de nos prêtres
des fonctionnaires de l'Etat,
l'Eglise n'est pas reconnue
comme la vraie religion,
non, ce qu'elle est
à nos yeux,
mais comme la religion
du plus grand nombre des Français.
-Ca ne vous suffit pas ?
Rires
-En outre,
il y a les fameux
articles organiques,
ajoutés unilatéralement par Napoléon
pour contrôler l'Eglise,
et que je Saint-Siège
ne reconnaît pas.
La manière dont ce Concordat
a été appliqué,
surtout dans les derniers temps,
a fait de lui un instrument
d'oppression contre l'Eglise...
-C'est scandaleux !
Ces propos sont scandaleux !
-Veuillez me permettre de développer
ma pensée dans le calme.
J'ai besoin, croyez-le,
de toute ma tranquillité d'esprit.
-Chaque orateur
y a droit.
Protestations
-Parlez, monsieur l'abbé Gayraud !
...
-Je ne regarde pas le Concordat
comme l'idéal des rapports
entre l'Eglise et l'Etat.
Et cependant,
je n'hésite pas à déclarer
que je préfère encore
ce régime concordataire
à la séparation
que vous nous apportez.
Par la séparation,
l'Eglise deviendra
dans ce pays
une association
semblable
aux autres.
-C'était très bien, ça.
-Son caractère divin sera méconnu,
nié par la loi
et le gouvernement.
-Très bien !
-Messieurs,
toutes les opinions
pourront s'exprimer.
Ne perdez pas vos forces.
-Avec la séparation,
l'Etat lui-même perdra
son autorité sur le clergé
et compromettra
les avantages
que sa qualité
de première nation catholique
lui faisait dans le monde.
-C'est vrai.
-Vous prétendez accorder la liberté
à l'Eglise...
et vous lui enlevez
le budget des Cultes !
Je lis votre projet :
"La République
"ne reconnaît, ne salarie
"ni ne subventionne aucun culte."
Mais quel est le but
que vous vous proposez ?
Voulez-vous détruire
le catholicisme dans ce pays,
anéantir la religion ?
Voulez-vous entraver la liberté
des consciences chrétiennes,
catholiques, protestantes,
israélites ?
Nous avons des siècles
pour prendre nos revanches
et l'histoire nous apprend
qu'elles gagnent toujours.
Aussi, je vous en conjure,
messieurs,
si vous voulez faire oeuvre
libérale, pacificatrice,
si vous voulez, dans ce pays
profondément catholique malgré tout,
calmer les appréhensions légitimes
de nos consciences,
vous devez, vous devez,
non pas à cause de notre foi,
- non, je n'invoque pas cette raison
qui serait veine à vos yeux -
mais à cause du principe fondamental
de nos constitutions politiques
qui est le respect
de la liberté de conscience,
prendre les mesures
naturellement indiquées
pour donner à nos consciences
catholiques la satisfaction
qu'elles sont en droit de réclamer.
Applaudissements
N'oubliez pas qu'au-dessus des lois,
il y a le droit de Dieu
et la liberté
des consciences catholiques.
Sur ce point,
nous ne transigeons jamais.
Nous avons fait nos preuves
depuis 2000 ans.
Lorsque sonne l'heure
des persécutions,
quelles que violentes
qu'elles soient,
nous savons y mettre la tête,
et lorsque nous y aurons
mis la tête, prenez-y garde,
vous serez les vaincus, messieurs.
Applaudissements
...
Musique sombre
J'ai fini.
Je m'excuse
d'avoir si longtemps retenu
votre attention.
Je suis venu à cette tribune
parler, non pas tant
en catholique et en prêtre,
concitoyen, soucieux
de la paix sociale de son pays.
Si vous ne voulez pas accepter
la motion que je propose,
je suis persuadé
que vous le regretterez un jour.
Je prévois de grands maux,
de grands malheurs
pour l'Eglise et pour la France.
C'est la guerre
que vous nous déclarez.
que vous nous apportez.
-Et nous la ferons !
Protestations
-Quoi qu'il en soit,
je tiens à l'affirmer
du haut de cette tribune :
c'est avec une grande tristesse
que je verrai le vote de ce projet.
Si c'est un gant
jeté à la face de l'Eglise,
eh bien nous le relèverons
et nous verrons qui reculera.
Applaudissements et protestations
Musique intense
...
-Bravo, monsieur l'abbé.
Magnifique, merci
pour la France catholique.
...
-Pour nous, l'idéal,
c'est l'union de la société civile
et de la société religieuse.
Voulez-vous anéantir la religion ?
Vous allez ouvrir
une période de troubles,
en allumant dans ce pays
une sorte de guerre civile.
Nous avons des siècles
pour prendre nos revanches,
et l'histoire nous apprend
qu'elles gagnent toujours.
...
-Après le prêche enflammé
du prêtre Gayraud,
les conversations vont bon train
au Palais Bourbon.
Le silence du gouvernement
est très commenté.
Ni le président du conseil
ni le ministre
des Cultes ne semblent décidés
à se mettre en avant
dans un débat
qui leur a été imposé
par les députés.
-L'ordre du jour appelle
la discussion
du projet portant séparation
des églises et de l'Etat.
Musique à suspense
-C'est donc Aristide Briand,
le rapporteur de la Commission,
qui va défendre la séparation.
Aristide Briand
sera-t-il à la hauteur ?
Lycéen, il avait séduit Jules Verne
par sa forte personnalité.
Le jeune Briant, héros du roman
"Deux ans de vacances", c'est lui,
un adolescent français qui triomphe
de toutes les difficultés
sur l'île déserte.
En ira-t-il de même
dans l'hémicycle ?
...
Coups de tonnerre
Avocat spécialisé
dans les conflits du travail,
Aristide Briand
a la parole facile,
mais il n'en a pas moins subi trois
échecs aux législatives
avant d'entrer au Palais Bourbon.
Il n'est député que depuis
trois ans et ses collègues
s'étonnent
qu'un tel dossier
ait été confié à un débutant.
Le rapporteur est aussi desservi
par sa réputation sulfureuse.
Elevé dans le café-concert
tenu par ses parents,
Aristide Briand est présenté
par ses adversaires comme un cynique
et un débauché.
Né à Nantes,
il a dû partir à Saint-Etienne
pour devenir député
à cause d'un scandale de moeurs.
Jeune militant socialiste,
on l'a trouvé un jour en plein champ
avec la femme d'un important
banquier de la région.
Une cloche sonne.
...
Longtemps proche
de l'extrême gauche,
influencé par
l'anarcho-syndicalisme,
il est connu comme un collectiviste,
partisan de la grève générale.
Peu nombreux sont les députés
qui parient sur Aristide Briand.
Mais ses amis comptent
sur son art oratoire
et sur son habileté.
Applaudissements
...
-Messieurs...
En insistant auprès de vous
pour que vous repoussiez
la motion de monsieur
l'abbé Gayraud,
je craindrais de faire injure
à la Chambre car ce serait
la supposer capable de se déjuger
à un mois d'intervalle.
Approbations
...
Il y a un mois,
vous avez déclaré
à une forte majorité
que les circonstances
ayant rendu inévitable la séparation
des églises et de l'Etat,
la discussion et le vote
de la réforme s'imposaient
dans cette session-même.
C'était un engagement solennel
pris en pleine connaissance de cause
et devant le pays tout entier.
La situation, messieurs,
est restée identiquement
la même.
Les difficultés avec Rome
ne se sont pas aplanies
et ne le seront jamais
car elles tiennent
à des causes profondes
que ni le Saint-Siège,
ni la République
ne peuvent transiger.
Toutes les causes
de conflit persistent.
Pour la République,
les principaux avantages
du Concordat, tout le Concordat,
sont dans les articles organiques
que Rome n'a pas reconnus.
A toutes les époques,
Elle a déclaré
les tenir pour nuls
et non avenus.
La doctrine fondamentale
de l'Eglise s'oppose formellement
à ce qu'elle
les reconnaisse jamais.
C'est la tare originelle
de cette convention
interlope née dans la contrainte
et dans la ruse.
Applaudissements
...
A la suite de violations
successives
et systématiques
du Concordat,
les relations avec Rome
ont dû
être rompues,
et vous avez reconnu
que la situation
appelait une réponse rapide
et que la seule qui fut à la fois
acceptable et conforme
à la dignité et aux intérêts
de la République était la séparation
des églises
et de l'Etat.
Protestations
...
Il m'avait semblé
qu'un rendez-vous avait été pris
d'accord
avec la Chambre pour discuter
non plus sur une misérable
question de procédure
mais sur le fond-même
de la réforme.
Applaudissements
...
C'est à l'heure où la Chambre
s'apprête à entreprendre la tâche
qu'elle s'est assignée
qu'on lui propose
d'ajourner toute solution.
Que se passera-t-il ?
C'est très simple.
Si vous aviez
l'imprudence d'accorder
cet ajournement,
le Saint-Siège
ne manquerait pas,
et il aurait raison,
d'interpréter votre vote
comme le signe
d'une grande inquiétude,
comme la démonstration
de votre impuissance,
comme la preuve éclatante
que vous redoutez de prendre
les responsabilités de l'heure.
-Il croirait simplement
que vous respectez
le suffrage universel.
-Monsieur le comte
de Baudry d'Asson, je vous invite
à faire silence.
Le rapporteur seul
a la parole.
-Le Saint-Siège,
son attitude
n'en serait pas améliorée,
ni ses prétentions affaiblies,
mais ceci n'est rien à côté
de ce qui pourrait
se passer dans le pays même.
Les ennemis de la République
auraient beau jeu
dans cette partie-là.
Le champ serait ouvert
devant eux
à tous les mensonges,
à toutes les calomnies
contre ce régime.
Sur cette question
de la séparation
que vous auriez posée
mais sans la résoudre,
il leur serait loisible
de vous prêter les pires desseins,
les plus éloignées
de vos intentions.
Vous les verriez
parcourir les campagnes,
annonçant la fermeture
des églises.
-Ce sont des propos scandaleux !
-Avec raison.
-Nous devons montrer
la vérité aux électeurs.
-Veuillez faire silence.
Si vous ne pouvez pas
entendre des opinions différentes,
la discussion
ne peut pas continuer.
-Les ennemis
de la République,
vous les verriez parcourir
les campagnes
annonçant fermeture des églises,
proscription des prêtres,
persécution des fidèles
et les atteintes les plus graves
à la liberté de conscience.
Et vous, messieurs,
comment vous défendriez-vous
contre ces attaques si grossières
ou invraisemblables ?
Vous ne le pourriez pas.
Vous ne le pourriez pas car,
quand on a l'imprudence
de s'exposer à être jugé
sur des intentions,
on peut craindre toutes les erreurs,
toutes les injustices.
Messieurs, je vous le demande :
quel républicain
consentirait de gaieté de coeur
à jeter la République
dans une aventure aussi folle ?
-Faites un référendum
sur cette question !
Vous verrez le résultat !
-Il est inadmissible
qu'on ne puisse pas continuer
dans le calme
une discussion dans les termes
où celle-ci est menée.
-Si nous apportions au vote
d'un projet de séparation
la même intolérance
que vous mettez
dans cette discussion,
nous vous ferions une mauvaise loi
contre laquelle
vous auriez raison de protester.
Mais je n'insiste plus,
je m'excuse d'en avoir tant dit
pour démontrer
à quel point est inacceptable
cette motion d'ajournement.
Cette discussion
aura tout de même valu
à l'Eglise un petit délai.
Dans les circonstances
où nous sommes,
c'est tout ce que nous pourrons
faire pour elle.
Applaudissements
-Bravo !
Bravo !
...
-Doué d'un talent d'orateur
qui a étonné la Chambre,
Aristide Briand
a défendu la séparation
sans avoir eu besoin
de détailler le contenu du texte.
Bon tacticien,
le rapporteur a mis les députés
devant leurs responsabilités
au moment où l'ouverture
du débat parlementaire
crée dans le pays
une agitation qui ne peut durer.
-Je mets aux voix la motion
de monsieur
l'abbé Gayraud.
Qui est pour ?
Qui est contre ?
Elle n'est pas adoptée.
-Mais Aristide Briand n'est pas
au bout de ses peines.
Après avoir séduit les modérés,
il doit encore affronter
l'extrême gauche,
qui lui reproche
la tiédeur de son texte.
Maurice Allard,
député socialiste du Var,
a déposé un contre-projet.
Fils d'un notaire tourangeau,
il ne manque jamais l'occasion
d'occulter ses origines bourgeoises
par des positions
doctrinales ultra rouges.
Ancien avocat devenu journaliste,
le député de Draguignan
est connu
pour sa facilité de parole
et sa verve caustique.
En matière religieuse,
Maurice Allard passe
pour un anticlérical
des plus enragés.
Dès 1903,
il a réclamé
la fermeture de l'ambassade
de France auprès du Vatican.
Plusieurs fois,
il a demandé la suppression
des aumôneries dans les lycées.
Mécréant notoire, athée déclaré,
il parle de faire condamner
tout prêtre
qui invoquerait un miracle.
L'Eglise étant à ses yeux
l'ennemie de la République,
aucun compromis
ne lui paraît souhaitable.
Or, on murmure à la Chambre
qu'Aristide Briand a dîné
avec des ecclésiastiques
pour négocier le texte
et aplanir les difficultés.
La fine diplomatie du rapporteur
n'est pas du goût
de son collègue Maurice Allard,
qui veut mettre le clergé à genoux
en confisquant les églises,
les cathédrales,
les séminaires,
les presbytères
et tout bien mobilier et immobilier
des communautés religieuses.
Dans le texte de la Commission,
les lieux de culte appartiennent
à l'Etat,
mais ils sont mis
à la disposition des fidèles
par l'intermédiaire
d'associations cultuelles
constituées à cet effet.
Pour Maurice Allard,
l'Etat doit récupérer les bâtiments
pour des usages profanes.
Son contre-projet
pourrait mettre en difficulté
Aristide Briand,
dont la modération n'est pas
appréciée sur tous les bancs.
L'horloge retentit.
...
Applaudissements
-La Chambre est maintenant saisie
du contre-projet
de M. Maurice Allard,
à qui je donne la parole.
-Messieurs,
je ne me dissimule pas
la difficulté de ma tâche.
J'ai contre moi toute la droite,
le centre-gauche,
la Commission,
le gouvernement
et probablement une partie
de la gauche
qui a déjà approuvé et adopté
le texte du gouvernement
et de la Commission
sans l'avoir sans doute
examiné suffisamment.
C'est à cette partie
de la gauche
que je m'adresserai
tout particulièrement.
Je tâcherai de lui démontrer
que le projet gouvernemental
ne répond en aucune façon
aux desiderata
des républicains.
Je veux débarrasser le débat
de toute considération
juridique oiseuse
Ce que je reproche
à la Commission,
c'est d'avoir méconnu
cette différence essentielle
qui existe
entre la liberté de conscience
et la liberté religieuse.
Cette confusion est manifeste
dans l'article premier
du texte gouvernemental
qui dit que
"la République assure
la liberté de conscience
"et garantit le libre
exercice des cultes."
La liberté religieuse n'est pas
la même chose
que la liberté de conscience.
L'une peut très bien exister
sans l'autre.
Ce que je reproche
à la Commission,
c'est d'avoir méconnu
cette distinction car,
cette distinction faite,
nous avons le droit
de ne pas laisser se constituer,
au milieu de l'Etat laïque
et contre lui,
cet Etat religieux particulier,
cette société religieuse
qui devient forcément
un danger véritable
quand elle est animée,
comme l'Eglise,
d'un esprit
essentiellement hostile
à tout progrès
et à toute civilisation.
-Oh ! Oh !
-Ca suffit !
-Scandaleux !
-Voilà, je crois,
ce que la Commission n'a pas compris
d'une façon suffisamment nette.
Il ne faut pas se leurrer
sur le sens du mot "séparation",
qui n'a aucun sens
si on ne lui applique pas
des idées précises,
des idées déterminées.
Il y a telle ou telle séparation
dont l'Eglise
peut très bien s'accommoder,
mais nous, libres penseurs,
quelle est la séparation
que nous voulons ?
Ce ne peut être
que celle qui amènera
la diminution de la malfaisance
de l'Eglise et des religions.
-Quel aveu !
-Voici le résultat le plus palpable
de votre séparation.
Au lieu de désarmer l'Eglise,
vous lui donnez des armes.
Tout se borne à lui retirer
le budget des cultes,
mais vous mettez par contre
à sa disposition
des biens soumis jusqu'à présent
au contrôle administratif.
Vous les lui abandonnez
en toute propriété,
avec la faculté
de les détourner de leur but
et de les employer à la lutte
contre la République.
Vous spoliez la nation
au profit de l'Eglise !
-OH !
-Ca suffit !
Protestations
...
Ces biens qui,
autrefois, étaient affectés
à un service public
doivent rester affectés
à un service public.
-Mais puisqu'on le supprime !
-Si vous le supprimez,
ces biens trouveront
une autre destination.
La nation en fera l'usage
qu'elle croira devoir en faire.
Voilà quelle est
la véritable solution,
la seule solution et,
j'ajoute, la solution équitable.
-Une confiscation n'est pas
une solution équitable.
-Qu'est-ce que je demande
à la gauche ?
Je demande à la gauche
de décider que l'Eglise,
danger politique
et danger social,
doit être combattue
de toutes les façons.
Je m'étonne que,
au moment où nous entreprenons
contre l'Eglise
un combat décisif,
on nous demande de déposer les armes
et de lui offrir
un projet si libéral,
tel qu'elle-même
n'aurait jamais osé le souhaiter.
Je ne vous dissimule pas
que mon contre-projet
tend à ce que la religion
devienne la chose anormale
et que l'areligion,
avec un A privatif,
devienne la chose normale.
Je ne vous cache pas
que mon contre-projet
tend à déchristianiser
le pays.
-Voyez-vous cela ?
...
-C'est une opinion.
J'ai le droit de l'exposer !
Je crois, messieurs,
que le christianisme
est un obstacle permanent
au développement social
de la République
et à tout progrès
vers la civilisation.
Il faut le dire très haut :
il y a incompatibilité
entre l'Eglise
et tout régime républicain.
Le christianisme est
un outrage à la raison,
à la nature.
...
Il suffit de lire l'histoire
pour s'en convaincre.
Quand le Dieu anthropomorphe
des Juifs
quitta les bords du Jourdain
pour aller conquérir
le monde méditerranéen,
la civilisation disparut
du bassin de la Méditerranée.
Il faut remercier
les empereurs romains
qui ont combattu
de toutes leurs forces
l'invasion de cette philosophie
puérile et barbare,
si contraire au panthéisme
et au naturalisme de notre race.
...
Oh, le christianisme
quitta Rome et la Grèce
où il avait étouffé
toute civilisation,
il n'y avait plus que ruines
et décombres.
Quand il arriva en France,
il n'y eut plus en notre pays
ni art, ni lettres, ni sciences.
Il fallut
la Renaissance,
la Révolution,
pour redonner
au cerveau de notre race
sa toute-puissance
et sa possibilité de progrès.
Sous l'influence
du judéo-christianisme,
toute lumière avait disparu.
Il n'y avait plus que ténèbres.
Aujourd'hui encore,
combien de progrès
ne sont pas réalisés
parce que nous traînons
derrière nous
le lourd boulet
du judéo-christianisme,
avec son cortège de préjugés
et de mensonges conventionnels ?
...
Le tourment de l'infini, direz-vous,
ne faut-il pas le satisfaire ?
Rires
Que faisons-nous
de l'idéal religieux ?
...
Il est vrai, messieurs,
que nous avons tous,
plus ou moins,
le tourment de l'infini.
Je vous assure qu'à gauche,
nous nous penchons volontiers
sur le problème de l'infini,
mais nous ne cherchons pas
à le résoudre,
car à nos yeux,
il ne peut pas être résolu.
Nous ne comprenons pas
l'infini de la même façon
que vous.
Pendant que vous prétendez
détenir la vérité,
nous autres, nous voulons dire
aux hommes et aux enfants :
personne ne détient la vérité !
A toi, jeune homme,
avec l'acquis
de ton instruction,
avec les données intellectuelles
que tu pourras apprendre
dans les écoles publiques
et dans tes études personnelles,
à toi de te constituer
ta philosophie personnelle
et de trouver ta manière
d'envisager le problème de l'infini.
Nous n'admettons pas
qu'un homme,
le prêtre, vienne nous imposer
ses idées, ni dogmes,
ni religion !
-Je veux citer
un prospectus que j'ai reçu.
Ses auteurs trouvent
leurs adresses
dans le Bottin et l'envoient
à tout le monde.
Il s'agit
des religieuses franciscaines
de Romorantin.
Rires
...
On tient boutique,
chez ces religieuses,
des objets les plus hétéroclites.
Pour une somme modique,
on vous adressera le scapulaire
de saint Antoine propre
à retrouver les objets perdus,
...
ou une bénédiction miraculeuse
de Saint François d'Assise,
imprimée
sur étoffe
avec le portrait !
On vend aussi une amulette
dont le principal effet est
de favoriser les accouchements.
Ou la collection
des prières
qui font gagner les procès.
L'audience rit.
-Oui, oui !
Nous protestons,
comme vous,
contre ces pratiques.
Le Christ ne s'est mis
qu'une fois en colère.
C'est quand il a chassé
les marchands du temple.
-Monsieur Gayraud.
Quand nous recherchons
un idéal,
nous n'allons pas le chercher
chez les franciscaines
de Romorantin.
-Nous non plus !
Brouhaha
-Alors que voulons-nous,
nous, à gauche ?
Eh bien nous voulons
que les hommes
se préoccupent un peu plus
du monde extérieur,
qu'ils sachent se faire leur paradis
sur terre sans aller le chercher
dans un monde imaginaire.
Acclamations
En attaquant les religions,
nous faisons oeuvre
de progrès social !
Nous tentons
de faire disparaitre
un des moyens les plus puissants
que possède encore
la bourgeoisie
pour tenir le peuple en esclavage.
Et c'est pourquoi,
messieurs,
je vous demande de voter
mon contre-projet,
le seul
capable de faire disparaître
ces idées
et la diffusion
et la diffusion des idées
religieuses, des idées mystiques
et superstitieuses
et d'émanciper tous ceux
qui, actuellement,
suivent encore
les pratiques de certains cultes !
Applaudissements nourris
...
Musique victorieuse
Musique douce
...
-S'il fallait donner
un nom au contre-projet
de monsieur Allard,
je crois qu'on pourrait l'appeler
"projet de suppression
des églises
"par l'Etat".
-Très bien !
Applaudissements
-Au lieu de compter
sur la puissance
de la raison et la vérité,
notre collègue,
dans sa hâte
d'en finir avec la religion
se tourne vers l'Etat
et l'appelle au secours.
Ah !
il l'appelle au secours
de la libre pensée et il le somme
de commettre,
au service de la libre pensée,
la faute qu'il a commise
au service
de l'Eglise
et que nous lui avons reproché.
Eh bien cela,
ce n'est pas la conception
de la libre pensée,
du moins,
telle que je l'interprète.
Nous avons déposé
un projet de séparation
très net,
mais aussi très large, équitable,
sachant concilier les droits
et les intérêts
de l'Etat avec le souci
de la liberté de conscience.
C'est,
à l'heure actuelle,
le seul projet dont le vote soit
possible et même désirable.
Je supplie
mes amis d'extrême gauche
de résister au désir
d'une manifestation anticléricale
qui resterait inefficace...
Protestations
Et donnerait ennemis de la
République une arme dangereuse.
Je connais mon ami Allard.
Je sais combien
il est perspicace, avisé
et je connais
son attachement à la République.
Je reste convaincu
qu'en déposant son contre-projet,
il aura surtout voulu exposer ici
sa doctrine philosophique.
Je me félicite
de cette initiative !
Elle nous a permis d'écouter
un discours plein de verve,
de fantaisie
et d'originalité !
-Surtout beaucoup
de fantaisie !
-Elle aura permis
de constater
qu'il y a des nuances
et qu'entre le contre-projet
de Maurice Allard
et celui de la Commission,
certaines distances
restent à parcourir.
Applaudissements
...
-Monsieur Briand !
Monsieur Briand
n'a répondu que de façon
très sommaire à mes arguments.
J'ai dit qu'il y avait
un grand danger pour la République
à offrir, en toute propriété,
aux associations cultuelles,
qui seront,
en même temps
des associations politiques,
des biens qui sont en réalité
des biens nationaux.
Le danger
est de maintenir
l'unité de l'Eglise
et d'empêcher l'Eglise,
après séparation,
de se diviser
en petites églises
et associations cultuelles.
Vous maintenez ainsi
l'unité du bloc romain !
Nous n'avons pas
à provoquer des schismes,
mais nous ne sommes pas là non plus
pour les empêcher !
Rires et brouhaha
...
-La parole est à monsieur
Jean Jaurès.
Musique intrigante
...
-Jean Jaurès prépare
son discours.
A 45 ans,
le député du Tarn
s'est imposé comme chef de file
des socialistes français.
Normalien,
professeur de philosophie,
c'est lui qui, en avril 1905,
s'apprête à fédérer les différentes
tendances du mouvement ouvrier
en un seul et même
parti politique,
la SFIO,
Section française
de l'Internationale ouvrière.
...
Jaurès est l'homme
de l'unité,
l'homme de la synthèse.
Lecteur de Karl Marx, il ne fait
pourtant pas de la lutte des classes
le moteur de l'histoire.
Le socialisme de Jaurès
est l'approfondissement
de l'idéal républicain,
l'application à la propriété
des droits de l'homme et du citoyen.
...
Sur la séparation,
le grand tribun a d'abord étonné,
en gardant le silence.
Partisan
de la laïcité,
Jaurès
n'est pas fermé
aux idées religieuses.
Ses propres amis,
en 1901,
avaient été scandalisés d'apprendre
que sa fille
avait fait
sa première communion.
...
Musique grave
On sait maintenant
que le silence de Jaurès était
purement tactique.
Le leader socialiste peaufine
ses arguments.
Son papier restera dans sa poche,
car Jaurès parle
sans texte sous les yeux,
mais les députés s'attendent
à un discours décisif.
Musique d'espoir
Aristide Briand et Maurice Allard
défendent deux textes différents
et inconciliables.
Seule l'intervention de Jean Jaurès
peut décider l'extrême gauche
à appuyer la Commission.
L'article 4, en particulier,
déplaît aux anticléricaux.
La création
d'associations cultuelles,
conforme aux voeux des évêques,
leur semble une concession exagérée.
Les plus acharnés veulent
des schismes
pour affaiblir l'Eglise.
Si les associations cultuelles
se constituaient
hors de la hiérarchie de l'Eglise,
sur un modèle
démocratique, de multiples
dissidences viendraient rompre
l'unité de l'Eglise catholique
et ruiner l'autorité du pape.
C'est ce que recherchent
les anticléricaux.
Aristide Briand, qui ménage l'Eglise
pour rassurer les modérés,
doit aussi convaincre les libres
penseurs pour avoir une majorité.
...
La gauche va-t-elle s'unir
ou se diviser ?
-La parole est à monsieur
Jean Jaurès.
-Les observateurs
s'accordent à dire
qu'un éclatement du camp républicain
serait fatal à la séparation.
Musique intrigante
...
-Messieurs,
cette loi va attribuer, demain,
des biens
à des associations cultuelles
régulièrement investies
et en harmonie
avec l'organisation
de l'Eglise catholique.
On a dit qu'on ne voulait pas
préparer de schisme,
mais qu'on ne voulait pas non plus
les empêcher.
Et cependant,
il en est
qui paraissent concevoir
que l'Eglise catholique
sera diminuée
dans sa puissance.
Non par le progrès direct
de la pensée libre
et de la science,
mais...
Par je ne sais quelle...
Déliquescence obscure
du dogme
où ils espéreraient
entrevoir,
un jour,
je ne sais quelle
nuance de schisme
vaguement assortie
à leurs aspirations intérieures.
Je ne voudrais pas me donner
un air d'outrecuidance
en résumant
en une formule trop simple
le génie
de l'histoire même de notre pays,
mais je crois pouvoir dire,
historiquement,
ceci :
la France n'est pas...
Schismatique
elle est...
Révolutionnaire !
Applaudissements nourris
...
Tantôt,
elle marche avec Rome,
comme aux temps lointains
où les barbares francs se faisaient,
contre les autres barbares,
les serviteurs
et les exécuteurs
de la pensée
de l'évêque de Rome.
Puis,
quand notre pays...
Echappe
aux prises de Rome,
quand il se dresse contre elles,
il ne se refuse point à demi,
il ne se réfugie pas
dans l'incertitude
des compromis !
Lorsque...
Aux XIIe et XIIIe siècles,
notre...
Intrépide et ardente
France méridionale
se levait
contre le despotisme de l'Eglise,
ce n'est pas
un schisme.
Ce n'est même pas une hérésie,
qu'elle promulguait,
c'était
toute une autre métaphysique,
toute une autre religion !
Puis,
au XVIe siècle,
quand ce grand mouvement
de la Réforme se produit,
quand éclate
cet admirable réveil
des consciences individuelles,
ce mouvement
grandit en Allemagne,
il grandit en Angleterre
et en Hollande.
En France,
il se heurte à la résistance
de l'immense majorité.
Pourquoi ?
Est-ce parce que la France était
au-dessous de la Réforme ?
Non, messieurs !
c'est parce que, déjà,
de grands
génies comme Rabelais
avaient entrevu
toute la grandeur future
de la science libre !
Parce qu'ils avaient
glorifié symboliquement les voiles
des navires,
mettant en communication
les terres et les mers,
et aussi les livres,
les papiers de ces livres,
qui mettent en communication
les esprits !
Musique d'espoir
Rabelais disait :
"L'humanité
"ira plus haut encore.
"Après avoir conquis les mers
et la terre,
"elle s'élèvera
"vers les hauteurs de l'espace."
Et devançant
Hugo,
il annonçait :
"L'humanité ira loger, un jour,
à l'enseigne des étoiles."
...
C'est parce que notre génie
français
avait cette admirable audace
d'espérance
et d'affirmation
dans la pensée libre
qu'il s'est réservé,
dans la Réforme,
afin de se conserver
tout entier
pour la Révolution !
Applaudissements nourris
...
Toute notre histoire
proteste
contre je ne sais quelle tentation
de substituer
les compromis incertains
et tâtonnants du schisme
à la marche délibérée
de l'esprit vers la pleine
lumière,
vers la pleine science
et l'entière raison !
C'est...
Sans équivoque,
c'est sans ambiguïté.
C'est en respectant,
dans la limite même
de leur fonctionnement,
les principes d'organisation
des églises
et c'est en dressant
contre ces églises
la grande association des hommes
travaillant au culte nouveau
de la justice sociale
et de l'humanité renouvelée,
c'est par là
et non
par des schismes incertains
que vous ferez progresser
ce pays
conformément à son génie.
Voilà pourquoi
l'oeuvre que la Commission
nous soumet,
oeuvre de loyauté,
oeuvre...
Hardie dans son fond,
mais qui ne cache aucun piège,
qui ne dissimule
aucune arrière-pensée,
est conforme
au véritable génie
de la France républicaine.
Musique d'espoir
Nous ne faisons pas
un oeuvre de brutalité.
une oeuvre...
De sournoiserie.
Nous faisons une oeuvre
de sincérité.
C'est là
le caractère du travail
de la Commission.
Et voilà pourquoi
je m'y rallie !
Applaudissements nourris
...
C'est parce que notre génie
français
avait cette admirable audace
d'espérance
et d'affirmation
dans la pensée libre
qu'il s'est réservé
dans la Réforme,
afin de se conserver
tout entier
pour la Révolution !
Nous faisons une oeuvre
de sincérité.
-Je mets aux voix le contre-projet
de monsieur Maurice Allard.
Qui est pour ?
Qui est contre ?
Il n'est pas adopté.
Applaudissements
et acclamations
...
Musique douce
-Revenus au texte de la Commission,
les députés s'enlisent
dans l'examen des amendements.
Le gouvernement reste
étonnamment absent,
trop peureux de faire
durer un débat qui retarde
opportunément l'ouverture
de dossiers sensibles
comme l'instauration d'un impôt
sur le revenu ou la création
de retraites ouvrières.
...
Allard n'a pas renoncé
à la provocation.
Les anticléricaux veulent
remplacer les fêtes religieuses
par des jours fériés laïcs.
Certains prônent l'interdiction
de la soutane.
Les libres penseurs ne voient pas
qu'avec leur surenchère,
ils rendent service
à Aristide Briand.
A droite et jusqu'au sein
de l'Eglise,
les plus raisonnables commencent
à voir ce texte
comme un moindre mal.
Seule une fraction
du monde catholique
refuse en bloc le débat.
Armand de Baudry d'Asson demeure
intransigeant.
Député royaliste de la Vendée,
commandeur de l'ordre pontifical
de Saint Grégoire le Grand,
il défend l'alliance
du trône et de l'autel.
Pour lui, point de salut
sans la monarchie.
Un de ses ancêtres est tombé,
armes à la main,
en luttant
contre les républicains.
Il en est fier.
Député des Sables-d'Olonne
depuis 29 ans,
Baudry d'Asson n'a cessé
de combattre la République.
En 1880, déjà,
il s'est montré si virulent
que Gambetta,
qui présidait la Chambre,
l'avait fait saisir
dans l'Hémicycle. Après une bagarre
mémorable
avec les gardes républicains,
le comte fut enfermé
pendant 24 heures.
Il passa la nuit
au "petit local",
la cellule de dégrisement
du palais Bourbon.
Propriétaire,
éleveur de chevaux,
Armand de Baudry d'Asson n'obéit
à personne.
Sportif, combatif,
il a mené la vie dure
au cabinet d'Emile Combes.
Musique intrigante
...
Le vieil aristocrate peut
encore cogner,
mais son combat est-il toujours
le même que celui de l'Eglise ?
L'abbé Gayraud, en effet,
semble s'éloigner
de son allié vendéen.
-La parole est à monsieur
l'abbé Gayraud.
-Messieurs,
vous nous avez accordé
des satisfactions
considérables,
en rédigeant le texte
de façon à parer
au péril de schisme,
en nous garantissant
la jouissance
gratuite et indéfinie
des édifices
du culte,
mais ma conscience m'oblige
à vous demander
que la loi de séparation
soit respectueuse
des exigences de ma foi.
Il faut que vous le sachiez,
la constitution
de l'Eglise n'est pas
une constitution
démocratique.
-Nous le savions !
-Ca ne veut pas dire que l'Eglise
catholique n'aime pas la démocratie.
-Parfaitement !
-La constitution de l'Eglise est
monarchique !
Rires
Applaudissements
Vous ne devez rien
introduire
qui soit contraire
à cette organisation.
-Ah bon ?
-Votre texte ne pourra
être acceptable
qu'au temps
qu'il aura été accepté
par le pape.
-Vous êtes plus papiste
que le pape !
-Vous voulez ouvrir une ère
d'agitation !
Je ne m'y associerai pas !
Je proteste dès maintenant
contre votre tyrannie !
-Ce sont vos paroles
qui ouvrent cette ère.
-Nous protestons !
-Pour être digne de la liberté,
il faut savoir
respecter celle d'autrui !
-De liberté,
monsieur Briand,
vous n'êtes pas brillant !
-Monsieur de Baudry d'Asson,
je dois constater
que jusqu'ici,
cette discussion
s'est poursuivie
dans le calme.
-J'estime
qu'un catholique
digne de ce nom,
qu'un royalise dévoué
ne peut voter ce texte.
Je vote donc contre,
au nom de la France
catholique
et de la liberté !
J'ai été à la peine,
j'ai été au combat,
je veux rester jusqu'au jour
où sonnera l'heure de la prospérité
pour notre malheureux pays,
L'heure du relèvement national.
-Oui.
-L'heure du bonheur
et de la joie.
L'heure de la délivrance !
Pour cela,
il faut d'abord
arrêter les persécutions
religieuses !
La cloche retentit.
Dieu avec nous !
-DIEU AVEC NOUS !
-Dieu avec nous !
-Non !
Plus de ces lois infernales,
qui empêchent nos enfants
de connaître Dieu !
Ces lois odieuses,
qui permettent
de chasser nos religieux !
Plus de spoliation honteuse !
Plus de ces vols véritables !
Je déposerai un projet
sur le bureau de la Chambre,
ayant pour but
d'expulser,
ou même de coller au mur,
tous les traîtres à la patrie !
-BRAVO !
La cloche sonne.
-M. de Baudry d'Asson,
je vous rappelle à l'ordre.
Je vous prie de respecter
le déroulement de la séance !
Musique de tension
...
Applaudissements timides
-Vive la France catholique !
-BRAVO.
-Vive la France aux Français !
-BRAVO !
...
Applaudissements
-Nous allons maintenant
examiner l'amendement
de monsieur Maurice Allard,
visant à décider
que cesseront
d'être jours fériés
ceux qui n'auront pas
pour objet exclusif la célébration
d'événements civils.
La parole est
à monsieur Maurice Allard.
-Mes chers collègues.
Quand demain,
nous aurons voté la séparation,
la République,
par un illogisme choquant,
fêtera encore la naissance
de Christ, sa résurrection...
Cris de protestations
Son ascension au Ciel !
Je crois que,
si nous voulons vraiment
que la laïcisation
ne soit pas un vain mot,
nous devons supprimer
les jours fériés religieux.
-Ce sont des propos scandaleux !
...
-Je ne vous demande
que de leur substituer
des jours fériés laïcs !
Gloussements
De même que l'Eglise
emprunta autrefois au paganisme
ces jours fériés,
je demande que nous empruntions
aujourd'hui à l'Eglise
ses jours de fête !
Huées
A Noël, nous fêterons
le solstice d'hiver,
à la Saint-Jean,
le solstice d'été...
A Pâques,
au lieu de célébrer
la résurrection miraculeuse
d'un mystique nommé Jésus,
dont l'existence même
est hypothétique,
eh bien, nous célébrerons
la renaissance
de la vie organique !
Je demande à la Chambre,
pour une laïcisation complète
de l'Etat,
de voter mon amendement.
Applaudissements
...
-Malgré sa poésie,
l'amendement a été repoussé
par la Commission.
-Même avis du gouvernement ?
-Evidemment.
-Je le mets aux voix.
Qui est pour ?
Contre ?
Il n'est pas adopté.
Je suis saisi
d'un nouvel amendement
de monsieur Maurice Allard
visant à interdire
le port du costume ecclésiastique
en ville.
Protestations
-De mieux en mieux !
Ils font claquer leur tablette.
...
-Mes chers collègues.
Nous ne pouvons voir
dans le prêtre
un citoyen
comme tout autre.
Protestations
C'est lui, par ses prétentions
et affirmations,
qui se met en dehors
du droit commun.
La question sera différente,
sans doute,
quand le prêtre consentira
à ne plus parler
comme un être qui s'élève
au-dessus de la société entière,
à ne plus être
le représentant direct de Dieu.
Cela, vous me l'accorderez
volontiers,
le met vraiment dans une situation
privilégiée dans notre société.
Parler à Dieu,
parler au nom de Dieu,
est une chose considérable !
...
Enorme !
Le prêtre n'est pas
un être comme vous et moi.
Le prêtre
ouvre et ferme à son gré
les portes du paradis
et celles de l'enfer.
C'est terrible, cela,
monsieur Gayraud.
Le prêtre dispose,
sur les masses crédules,
d'une influence
que nous n'avons pas,
nous autres propagandistes,
arpentant les villes
en jaquette et en paletot.
-Parlez-nous donc
des tabliers
des francs-maçons !
-Nous sommes des hommes
comme les autres.
Le prêtre
qui a un homme à genoux,
qui passe pour avoir dans ses mains
les destinées futures...
Ah, mais messieurs !
Ce prêtre est puissant !
Il est le maître
de cette pauvre conscience
qu'il menace
de peines terribles.
Et il a, par suite,
une puissance d'action
que ne possède pas
le plus éloquent orateur.
-Vous avez les préfets pour vous.
Ricanements
-Messieurs, au risque d'étonner
notre honorable collègue,
je lui dirais
que le silence du projet de loi
au sujet
du costume ecclésiastique
qui semble le préoccuper si fort
n'est pas le résultat
d'une omission,
mais d'une délibération
mûrement réfléchie.
La Commission pense
que ce serait encourir,
pour un résultat problématique,
le reproche d'intolérance
et de s'exposer à un danger
bien plus grave :
le ridicule !
-Très bien !
-Ce que notre collègue
veut atteindre dans la soutane,
c'est le fait qu'elle distingue
des autres citoyens.
Une fois ôtée,
l'ingéniosité combinée
des tailleurs
et des prêtres aurait tôt fait
de créer un costume nouveau,
qui ne serait pas la soutane,
mais qui se distinguerait
du veston
pour permettre aux passants
de distinguer rapidement un prêtre.
Il serait téméraire d'attribuer
le prestige de l'Eglise
dans nos campagnes uniquement
à la forme du vêtement
des prêtres.
L'influence de l'Eglise
tient à d'autres causes,
plus difficile à détruire,
sinon, la libre-pensée
aurait triomphé depuis longtemps
du dogme,
monsieur Allard.
-Cet amendement
a-t-il plus de succès
que le précédent ?
Il n'est pas adopté.
Applaudissements
Je donne la parole,
sur l'ensemble du texte,
à monsieur Aristide Briand,
rapporteur de la Commission.
La sonnette retentit.
-Le 3 juillet 1905,
après 3 mois et demi de débats,
les députés doivent se prononcer
sur l'ensemble du texte.
Bien que fatigué,
Aristide Briand s'apprête à livrer
une dernière bataille.
Le petit député
de la Loire
va-t-il gagner son pari ?
L'effacement
du ministre des Cultes
donne la vedette
au rapporteur de la Commission.
Inconnu en début d'année,
Aristide Briand est maintenant
une célébrité nationale.
Cette loi qu'il a défendue seul
est sa loi.
Il souhaite qu'elle soit votée
à la plus large majorité,
mais aussi qu'elle soit comprise
et acceptée dans le pays.
La France de 1905 ne peut prendre
le risque de se déchirer
sur la question religieuse.
Le Kaiser Guillaume II
a fait connaître son ambition
de contrôler le Maroc.
C'est la crise de Tanger.
Le ton monte.
La guerre franco-allemande
menace d'éclater.
Pour Aristide Briand,
le succès personnel est acquis.
-Je donne la parole
sur l'ensemble du texte
à Aristide Briand,
rapporteur de la Commission.
Applaudissements timides
-Mais en montant à la tribune,
il sait que la paix civile,
la concorde, l'union des Français,
doit être à tout prix préservée.
C'est un homme d'Etat
qui est en train de naître.
-Sous l'influence
des passions politiques,
les hommes
nient le progrès
ne s'affirmant pas
par une violence
aux dépens de leurs adversaires.
Je tiens à le dire hautement :
le progrès ainsi compris
n'est pas
dans ma manière.
Applaudissements
...
Dans ce pays
où les catholiques
pratiquent leur religion,
par conviction réelle
ou par tradition de famille,
il était impossible d'envisager
une séparation
qu'ils ne puissent accepter.
On m'a fait grief
de certaines
concessions au centre
et à la droite.
Si j'avais fait
de cette réforme
une question d'amour-propre
personnelle,
comme quand on s'exalte
face à la grandeur de sa tâche
et qu'on se laisse porter
par le désir de la marquer
de son empreinte,
si je n'avais eu
que cette préoccupation,
c'était l'irrémédiable échec.
J'ai compris autrement
mon devoir et ai voulu réussir
la tâche donnée.
Pour cela,
sans perdre de vue un instant
les principes essentiels
de la réforme, qui tous...
Ont été respectés.
Je n'ai pas reculé
devant les concessions nécessaires.
Les collègues ayant combattu
la séparation et portant sur elle
un jugement
selon leur conscience,
seront bien forcés de reconnaître
que nous avons fait pour le mieux.
Maintenant, messieurs,
permettez-moi de vous dire
que la réalisation de cette réforme
aura pour effet désirable
d'affranchir ce pays
d'une vraie hantise,
sous l'influence de laquelle
il a éludé
des questions importantes,
d'ordre économique
ou social.
Ces grands problèmes
se poseront demain,
dès qu'auront disparu des programmes
les questions irritantes
qui passionnent
jusqu'à la haine
et gâchent en vaines discordes
les forces
les plus vives de la nation.
La réforme laissera le champ libre
à l'activité républicaine.
Pour qu'il en fût ainsi,
il ne fallait pas
de lutte confessionnelle.
La loi devait se montrer
respectueuse de chaque croyance
et leur laisser la faculté
de s'exprimer librement.
Protestations
...
Nous l'avons faite
de telle sorte que l'Eglise
ne puisse citer un prétexte
pour s'insurger
contre le nouvel état des choses.
-Pas du tout.
-C'est scandaleux !
C'est une honte !
-Monsieur Gayraud,
je ne m'explique pas
les paroles que vous prononciez
au début de cette discussion
quand vous disiez :
"Vous pensez accorder la liberté
à l'Eglise, mais vous ôtez
"le budget des cultes."
Monsieur Gayraud,
si l'Eglise
ne peut se passer de l'Etat,
c'est qu'elle est déjà morte !
-Je n'ai jamais dit cela,
monsieur Briand.
-Si ce n'est pas votre opinion,
vous devrez vous tenir
pour satisfait de cette loi.
Demain, vous ne pourrez plus
dire aux paysans
aux catholiques de France,
que la majorité républicaine
de cette Chambre
s'est montrée, à votre égard,
persécutrice et tyrannique,
car elle vous aura
généreusement accordé
tout ce que vos consciences
pouvaient exiger :
la justice et la liberté.
Musique triomphante
Applaudissements et acclamations
...
-La loi de séparation
des églises et de l'Etat est adoptée
à la Chambre des députés
par 341 voix contre 233.
Briand est ovationné
et son discours final est affiché
dans les 36 000 communes
de France.
...
Votée conforme par le Sénat
le 6 décembre 1905,
la loi est promulguée
le 9 décembre
et paraît
au Journal officiel le 11.
Au début de l'année 1906,
son application donne lieu
à des violences graves.
Les agents de l'Etat qui viennent
inventorier les biens des églises
font face aux prêtres et croyants
refusant d'ouvrir les tabernacles.
Musique de tension
Protestations
La crise des inventaires
fait tomber le gouvernement.
Dans le nouveau cabinet,
Aristide Briand
est nommé ministre des Cultes.
Avec Clémenceau,
ministre de l'Intérieur,
la décision est prise de suspendre
les inventaires
et d'appliquer la loi en douceur.
Pour Briand, c'est le début
d'une carrière sans équivalent.
Evoluant vers le centre,
l'ancien rapporteur de la loi
de séparation sera 25 fois ministre
et 11 fois président du Conseil,
un record inégalé.
Le père Gayraud,
malade,
meurt en cours de mandat
le 16 décembre 1911.
Armand de Baudry d'Asson,
aux élections de 1914,
laisse sa circonscription
à son fils, après 38 ans de mandat.
Il s'éteint l'année suivante,
sur ses terres de Vendée.
Jean Jaurès,
le tribun de la paix,
est assassiné le 31 juillet 1914,
à la veille
de la Première Guerre mondiale.
Musique martiale
Coups de canon
...
Dans les tranchées,
cléricaux et anticléricaux
partagent les mêmes épreuves.
A la fin de la guerre,
l'Alsace et la Moselle redeviennent
françaises, mais gagnent
un statut religieux particulier.
Dans les années 1920,
Aristide Briand deviendra l'artisan
du rapprochement franco-allemand,
ce qui lui vaudra
le Nobel de la Paix
en 1926.
C'est à la tribune de la Société
des Nations qu'en 1931,
il s'adresse aux gouvernements
du monde entier.
Applaudissements
...
-Plus de guerre.
Nous n'acceptons pas
que dans aucun cas,
pour aucune cause,
dans aucune circonstance,
la guerre,
qui fut clouée au pilori
comme un crime,
puisse se réveiller.
...
-Mais Aristide Briand
échoue à conquérir l'Elysée
et se retire dans sa propriété
de Cocherel, en Normandie.
Les parlementaires lui préfèrent
Paul Doumer,
l'ancien président de la Chambre
devenu président du Sénat.
Elu à la présidence de la République
le 13 mai 1931,
Paul Doumer est assassiné
moins d'un an plus tard
par un fou
qui se réclame du fascisme.
La République est en deuil.
Les années noires ont commencé.
Musique inquiétante
...
Après la mort
d'Aristide Briand
le 7 mars 1932,
Maurice Allard reste le dernier
grand témoin du débat de 1905.
Battu en 1910
et redevenu simple journaliste,
il vivra
jusqu'au 27 novembre 1942.
Il verra,
sous l'Occupation,
le gouvernement de Vichy
rechercher l'appui de l'Eglise.
...
De nombreux croyants
rejoignent la Résistance.
Vrombissements
Ils forment à la Libération
un important mouvement
de démocratie chrétienne.
La laïcité entre
dans le préambule
de la Constitution française
de 1946,
une valeur confirmée
en 1958
dans la Constitution
de la Ve République.
La France est
une république indivisible,
laïque, démocratique,
et sociale.
Elle assure l'égalité
devant la loi
de tous les citoyens,
sans distinction d'origine,
de race ou de religion.
Elle respecte
toutes les croyances.
Les relations
entre la République et l'Eglise
s'apaisent.
*-Charles de Gaulle au Vatican :
cela a permis au souverain pontife
de rappeler que l'oeuvre entreprise
actuellement par la France
devait servir les intérêts
de chaque peuple.
Les propos entre le Pape
et le chef de la Nation française
sont demeurés secrets,
mais ici comme à Milan
et au Quirinal,
des liens chaleureux
ont été renoués.
Musique grandiose
Cris
Musique de tension
-En 1989, la rentrée scolaire
est perturbée
par un incident inattendu.
Trois jeunes musulmanes
qui refusent
d'ôter leur foulard en cours
sont exclues
du collège Gabriel Havez
de Creil.
Protestations et klaxons
Motif :
atteinte à la laïcité
et à la neutralité
de l'école publique.
...
-Le problème
n'est pas des croyances,
le problème est
de la manifestation extérieure
de cette croyance
dans l'enceinte
des locaux scolaires, en classe.
-De nouveau, la France
s'interroge sur la laïcité.
*-LAICITE IMPOSEE !
NON, NON ! JAMAIS, JAMAIS !
...
-Nous avons fait
le choix libre.
Maintenant,
rien ne nous en détournera.
-La loi de 1905 revient
au centre du débat public.
-Si se produisent
comme ce sont produit des blocages,
c'est-à-dire des enfants
qui vont à l'école,
mais ils ne sont
pas les seuls,
il y a aussi
d'autres signes religieux
actuellement présents
à l'école, notamment
avec un foulard
sur la tête,
je préconise
que les directeurs d'établissements
et les enseignants
disent à ces enfants
et à leurs parents
qu'ils ne doivent pas venir
à l'école dans ces conditions.
S'il y a blocage
et s'il y a refus,
je dis alors :
"L'école doit accepter
et accueillir ces enfants".
Protestations
-Le gouvernement Rocard s'en était
remis au Conseil d'Etat.
Celui-ci, dans son avis
du 27 novembre 1989,
n'avait pu que rappeler
le droit en vigueur.
Si le port de signes religieux
n'est pas incompatible
avec la laïcité
et constitue même une liberté,
il ne doit pas
prendre un caractère ostentatoire
ou revendicatif,
ni devenir
un acte de pression,
de provocation,
de prosélytisme, de propagande,
et ne doit en aucun cas
porter atteinte
à la dignité de l'élève.
Le port de signes religieux
peut ainsi être réglementé.
Dans le même esprit,
la circulaire Bayrou de 1994
distingue les signes discrets
des signes ostentatoires.
11 décembre 2003 :
la commission Stasi
sur la laïcité rend son rapport
au président de la République.
Le 17 décembre,
Jacques Chirac se déclare favorable
à l'enseignement du fait religieux
et souhaite une loi
contre le port ostensible
de signes religieux à l'école.
-J'estime que le port de tenues
ou de signes
qui manifestent ostensiblement
l'appartenance religieuse
doit être proscrit
dans les écoles,
les collèges et les lycées publics.
Musique militaire
-Une mission parlementaire
d'informations
est constituée
sous Jean-Louis Debré.
Cette démarche aboutit
à la loi du 15 mars 2004,
selon laquelle,
dans les écoles, les collèges,
et les lycées publics,
le port de signes ou tenues
par lesquels les élèves
manifestent ostensiblement
une appartenance religieuse
est interdit.
...
Le modèle français de laïcité
ne signifie pas
l'abnégation du fait religieux.
Scintillements
L'homme ne serait pas l'homme
s'il ne s'interrogeait pas
sur l'origine du monde
et la fin des choses.
Le don de la vie
et l'énigme de la mort,
le lien mystérieux
de la matière et de l'esprit,
la conscience que chacun
a de lui-même :
comment en rendre compte ?
Musique relaxante
Les hommes se posent tous
les mêmes questions,
mais ils diffèrent
sur les voies de la connaissance.
Le vent souffle.
Faut-il préférer la raison logique,
la médiation intérieure,
la révélation d'en-haut ?
Cette recherche
n'est pas seulement individuelle.
...
Prophètes, messies et apôtres
ont laissé aux différents peuples
des règles de vie,
des articles de foi,
la morale issue des livres sacrés
quelques fois sévères.
...
Le culte peut prendre
des formes visibles,
démonstratives, exaltées, même.
Musique martiale intense
...
Musique douce
Les oiseaux chantent.
...
Chacun,
dans sa courte existence,
s'efforce de trouver son chemin.
...
Celui qui croit au ciel
voudrait tourner
toutes les âmes vers son Dieu.
...
Celui qui n'y croit pas
aimerait libérer les hommes
de leurs croyances,
s'il le faut, malgré eux.
L'un, dans sa ferveur,
souhaite renforcer la religion
par la puissance de l'Etat
pour soumettre les hommes
à la loi divine.
L'autre,
dans sa sagesse,
demande qu'on distingue
le pouvoir politique
du pouvoir religieux.
...
Le compromis de 1905
nous vient en héritage.
...
La laïcité n'est pas
une croyance de plus,
ni une religion de l'incroyance.
Elle signifie la neutralité
de l'Etat
en matière de religion.
C'est elle qui permet
à toutes les croyances
de coexister en paix
dans un même pays.
Elle garantit à chacun
la liberté de croire
et celle de ne pas croire,
la liberté de pratiquer
et celle de ne pas pratiquer.
...
Musique grandiose
Elle donne à tous la faculté
la plus rare dans le monde
et la plus précieuse
pour l'esprit :
la liberté de douter.
...
Aujourd'hui comme hier,
la laïcité est notre bien commun.
...
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA